PROFESSOR: All right, my trusty
$5 Timex watch says
it's five after the hour.
So I guess we might
as well begin.
I have corrected all the
problems that were turned in--
the puzzles, not problems,
puzzles.
And I just yesterday
got hold of the
photographs of you few people.
And I'd like to hand out the
papers individually so I can
start to put names together
with faces.
So I'll turn them back
individually next time.
I have one additional problem
set that for you.
And again, this is in the
form of a puzzle.
Be assured that this is the last
entertaining problem set.
From here on, we move
into drudgery--
tedious, drawn out things
that hopefully
will teach you something.
But this is the last one that's
done with a little bit
of tongue in cheek humor.
This one is a little more subtle
than the other two.
And for this one, I will hand
out a solution because I would
like to use these problems to
make a couple of basic points
about the nature of symmetry
theory in crystals.
So see how you do on this one.
OK, also before we begin, he
gets a little bit uneasy
before a crowd.
But I brought a little friend
in with me today.
And could someone hold
the box, please, so I
could take him out?
Sorry.
He gets a little bit nervous
before a crowd.
Come on, take it easy.
Take it easy.
This is Rodney.
He's an old friend of mine.
Rodney is a crystallographic
abomination.
Rodney has five-fold
symmetry--
impossible in crystallography,
an abomination.
Why did Rodney decide
to do this?
Anybody have any idea?
Why not six fold symmetry?
He's got five-fold symmetry.
Yuck!
But why?
There's always a reason for
things if you look carefully
enough and know what
questions to ask.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: He had narrow
symmetry.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, he had
narrow symmetry.
But he could do that-- what
if you were square?
Why not a square starfish?
Why five?
He did this for a reason.
He's been doing this for
probably a couple of million
years, he and his ancestors.
There has to be a reason.
OK, let me turn him over.
And maybe that will
give you a clue.
The backside is not nearly as
nice as the front side.
And in fact, if you look at
Rodney carefully, Rodney has
sutures between these
five arms.
OK, this is what he looks
like from the top.
But if you look at him from the
bottom, there are sutures
between these arms
that do this.
And these sutures are weak
points in his structure.
And by having five-fold
symmetry, he puts the suture
between this pair of arms
opposite the midpoint of the
opposite rib.
And that gives him a great deal
more structural integrity.
So when a large fish comes along
and gloms onto one of
his arms and shakes, he doesn't
split in half and end
his career prematurely.
What happens instead, at very
worst, the tip of the arm
breaks off.
And then, Rodney gets to scamper
away and make more
starfish or do whatever his
purpose in our environment is.
If he had an even-fold
symmetry,
that wouldn't happen.
He would really be
done in by a fish
grabbing hold and shaking.
AUDIENCE: What if [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's a very
good question.
If he had only three arms and
a fish glomed on and one arm
broke off, his mobility would
be greatly impaired.
In a way, he would go
hip, hop, flop.
Hip, hip, flop.
It'd be a pathetic thing.
So five is much more
advantageous than three.
AUDIENCE: Why not seven?
PROFESSOR: Why not seven?
That's a good question, too.
Would you believe that on the
Australian Barrier Reef, there
are starfish with nine-fold
symmetry?
Quite odd.
That's really a creepy
thing with all those
arms flopping around.
But as many things in our
environment in our natural
world, there's a reason for
things if you can only think
what it might be.
So we gave you another example
of a non-crystallographic
symmetry, the large cacti of the
Southwest, the saguaros.
And there are lots of
other ribbed casts.
They have symmetries that range
between 19 and 23 fold.
Why do you think they have
this rib structure?
Why can't they have a
nice, smooth trunk
like a birch tree?
Any idea there?
I'll give you a hint.
They live out in the desert.
There's not much water.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: More surface area
for the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
but that's bad.
That means they would
lose their water.
So things that don't
want to lose water
through their surface--
you're right-- try to minimize
their surface.
But you're onto something.
And it is exactly the
reverse of that.
Water is scarce.
So when it rains, this cactus
wants to soak up the moisture
and store it.
If he has this pleated
structure,
he's able to expand.
If he had a smooth surface
with minimal area,
he would just pop.
And that would be the end of
him or her, as the case may
be. "It" is probably the
appropriate term.
But anyway, there's the reason
for these many, many ribs.
It gives them the ability to
expand, store water, and then
contract when the water
evaporates.
So again, it's always
interesting to look at the
world around us and see examples
of things that are
strange because it's the strange
things that very often
can lead to penetrating
conclusions.
All right, last time we had
talked about chirality in
finite atomic structures,
molecules.
And I had pointed out-- but
did not make the obvious
observation--
I cannot think of a more
dramatic connection between
structure and properties, which
is what material science
is all about, than the very,
very different properties of
molecules that are of
opposite handedness.
We pointed out, for example,
that many pharmaceuticals are
of chiral molecules that exist
in right handed and left
handed forms.
And very often, one form of
one handedness has a very
different set of properties,
and in particular
pharmacological action, then
it it's enan enantiomorph.
So in the case of thalidomide,
one handedness of the molecule
acts as a tranquilizer.
The other handedness acts as
a source of birth defects.
One of the other ones less
familiar to me, but this is
[? ethambutol. ?]
It's used as a drug to
treat tuberculosis.
The molecule of opposite
handedness creates blindness.
The drug Ritalin that is used
to treat hyperactivity, one
handedness of the molecule
is absolutely useless.
So you only use half of
what you pay for.
So it's of great interest to
pharmaceutical companies to be
able to synthesize a molecule
of one particular handedness
with little if none
of the other one.
And I looked up a number
since we met last time.
It turns out that in 1997,
enantiomorph pure drugs were a
$400 billion dollar industry.
So again, this is structure
property relations in action.
So let me ask you another
question.
It turns out that products that
are derived from nature--
a good example being sugar,
which is produced by sugar
beets or sugar cane--
produces a molecule only
of one handedness.
They are [? enantiomer ?]
pure.
But every synthetic compound
that can exist in right handed
and left handed forms occurs
with equal probability.
So how do you make a
pharmaceutical of one
particular handedness?
And this is an interesting
question because I think it
was two years ago the Nobel
Prize in chemistry was given
to three people for their work
in being able to synthesize
molecules of a given
handedness.
Anybody an idea how you do it?
AUDIENCE: I don't have an idea
how you do it, but what do you
mean by one handedness
versus--?
PROFESSOR: OK, left handed
or right handed.
So my left hand is exactly the
same as my right hand, but I
cannot match them into
congruence with one another.
And we don't know how to
describe this other than we
used the term derived
from our physiology.
We say left handed
and right handed.
So when I was referring to a
molecule of one handedness--
and I'll bring in a Xerox copy
of a couple of examples.
There are many examples of
fairly common molecules which
can exist in one form in which
the hydroxyl group points out
this way, then another form
where the hydroxyl groups
points out this way.
Sorry, you should have
asked that earlier.
AUDIENCE: So if it's not the
same molecule, it would be
that molecule but--?
PROFESSOR: Chemically, it is
exactly the same concept.
But the way in which those
component models are
configured has the same number
of side groups, the same
number of appendages.
But they, don't have
a better word.
One is left handed.
One is right handed.
I'll give you some examples
next time.
Somebody else, you
had a question?
AUDIENCE: I was just going to
see if I could venture a guess
how they do it.
I was going to guess they use an
electric field that has its
bearings to set the right handed
course [INAUDIBLE] that
would make [? enantiomorphs ?]
or more advantageous
than [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
not a bad idea.
Anything that could bias the
energy of one configuration
over the other would do it.
But actually, no reason why you
should know how to do it.
If you knew how to do it, maybe
you could have gotten
the Nobel Prize instead
of these other guys.
But actually, you do it
through catalysis.
And you use a catalyst which
itself has chirality.
And that chirality favors the
formation of one molecule over
the other almost exclusively.
And that's why living
plants make--
or animals-- make chiral
molecules in just one
handedness as well.
So it's using a catalyst that
also has some chirality.
AUDIENCE: How do you get the
one hundred catalysts
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: How do
you have it--?
OK, there are lots
of materials.
Any crystalline material that
does not have a mirror plane
in it can exist in
chiral forms.
And one of the classic examples
of this is quartz.
Quartz is SiO2.
And quartz has actually only
a threefold symmetry.
But it forms crystals that look
prismatic, as though they
were hexagonal prisms.
And if I draw two of these
prisms side by side, you could
not tell which prism
was left handed and
which was right handed.
But quartz ends up growing with
a couple of little facets
on it that look like this.
They spiral up this way in a
crystal of one handedness and
they spiral up in the opposite
direction for a crystal of
opposite handedness.
So the external faces on the
crystal show you that this
crystal shape cannot be mapped
one into another.
They are of opposite
handedness.
And they have very different
properties.
And so here's an example.
I'm not answer your question.
I'm talking around it very
adroitly in the hope that if I
talk enough you will forget
what you asked.
But how do you make
a chiral catalyst?
Well, there are some materials
if you prepare them in a
single crystal form, once you
nucleate one enantiomorph,
that will continue to grow.
So I would presume one
could do exactly
the same with a catalyst.
Actually, the properties of
quartz are strikingly
different for these two
different forms.
If you would subject the crystal
to compression, this
crystal would develop
a positive
charge on the surface.
This crystal would develop
a negative
charge on the surface.
That's a property that we'll
discuss in detail later on.
That's something called
piezoelectricity, literally
pressure electricity.
So the nature of the charge
induced on the crystal is
different for the crystals
of the two chiralities.
OK, any other comment
or question?
OK, last time we had taken the
first small steps in what will
turn out to be a long and
protracted process of synthesis.
We've covered by now some of
the general notions of
operations that can exist in
a pattern, two dimensional
pattern of wallpaper or fabric
or a three dimensional pattern
that constitutes a crystal.
And we said that in three
dimensions, there are four
basic different operations that
can exist that tell you
how one part of the system
is related to another.
There is an operation
of translation.
And this has all the
characteristics of a vector,
magnitude and direction.
We summarize that translational
periodicity by a
set of fiducial markers that
are called lattice points.
And analytically, the
transformation takes the
coordinate x, y, z.
And if you do the operation
once, maps this to x plus a, y
plus b, z plus c where the
translation has components a,
b, and c in x, y, and
z directions.
Another operation is the
operation of reflection.
And what this operation does is
to take the coordinates of
an initial part of the space
atom or location and maps it
into some location where one
direction is reversed in sign.
Which direction that is or
whether it's a pair of
directions will depend on how
the reflection locus is
located relative to the
coordinate system.
Next, there was an operation
of rotation.
And this involves repeating
things at angular intervals.
Take the space or the location
of the atom and rotate it
through some angle, alpha,
about some rotation, a.
And in a sense, this is
a periodicity which is
reminiscent of translation
except translation strings
things out in a line.
Rotation wraps up the
directions about
some central axis.
But it's also periodic.
Then finally, in three
dimensions, there is another
operation called inversion.
And what this does is--
to could describe it as such
in literal terms--
take something and turns it
inside out to a point.
So if the inversion point were
at the origin, it would take
x, y, z, and map it into minus
x, minus y, minus z.
And then, we concluded last time
with a definition of a
vocabulary for indicating
analytically a single
operation, the set of operations
that constitutes
the symmetry element, and then
a geometric symbol for the
locus of that operation.
And for translation, we could
represent a single
operation by t.
The set of operations
could be--
and I'll use this customary
set of braces to
indicate the set--
this would be a one dimensional
lattice, a set of
operations, p, where p is
an integer times t.
The geometric symbol, it's
convenient to use an arrow
extending from one lattice
point to another.
But I emphasize that there's
no unique origin to the
translation.
We cannot be entitled to say
it sits here as opposed to
down here or down here.
There are an infinite number
of parallel directions that
could specify a given interval
between lattice points.
For rotation operations, the
notation for a single
operation in as much as we must
specify two things, the
point about which we rotate and
then the angular interval
about which we perform
the rotation.
And so we need to specify two
things, the location of the
axis, a point a, and
the angle, alpha,
through which we rotate.
The set of operations, the
rotation axis, is indicated by
an integer, n, where the
rotation part of the operation
is 2 pi divided by
the integer, n.
So we would use, for example, 2
to represent a rotation axis
where things were moved through
180 degrees, 3 for a
symmetry where things were
mapped through intervals of
120 degrees, and 22 for my
good friend, the Saguaro
cactus, which is left invariant
perhaps by a
rotation through 1/22 of 2 pi.
For the geometric symbol for a
rotation axis, we will use a
little polyhedron.
Triangle for a threefold axis.
Square for a fourfold axis.
For a twofold axis, the
polyhedron that had that
symmetry would be
a line segment.
So we'll take a little artistic
license and let the
middle of the line segment
bulge out a little bit.
Finally for inversion, for
reasons that will not become
clear for another meeting or
two, the single operation is
denoted one bar.
The set of operations of which
there are only two, inverting
and coming back again,
also indicated by
the symbol one bar.
And the geometric symbol for
the locus is a little, tiny
circle that's open large enough
to be noticed, but not
so large that it looks like an
atom in an atomic arrangement.
So there's our basic
bag of tricks.
And last time, we had already
used some simple geometry to
come to a rather astonishing
conclusion.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Reflection?
PROFESSOR: Reflection, that's
this middle one.
Whoops, not going to help.
Thank you very much.
I get excited and
carried away.
OK, reflection, the
second operation.
Single operation, although
crystallographers don't often
use it in condensed matter
physics, a single operation is
represented by the
symbol sigma.
Symbol for a mirror plane is
m, easily appreciated.
And the geometric locus across
which things are reflected
left to right and vice versa
is done with a bold, solid
line when you're looking down
parallel to the surface of the
reflection locus.
Then, I will now be caught up.
And I can set off on
something new.
We had said that in a pattern,
very often more than one of
these operations are combined
in a single space.
And one of the things that
must be present--
if the symmetry of
the entity we are
discussing is a crystal--
one of the things that must be
present is a translation.
And so I asked last time the
question, what if we want to
say that our space has a
translational periodicity
described by t.
And then, I add to one lattice
point a rotation operation, A
alpha, that has to get
translated to another location
where that operation,
A alpha, exists.
And if A alpha exists and I
repeat that translation by a
rotation alpha, I'm going to
have a sheath of translations
all separated by a
distance alpha.
If I single out the one that is
removed from the first by
an operation of rotation A alpha
in a counterclockwise
direction and single out from
that sheath another one that
is alpha away in the clockwise
direction.
Then, I have lattice points
at the end of all of these
translations.
But these two guys up here
are also lattice points.
And therefore, I have mucked up
to the entire construction
unless I can claim that this
distance between these two
lattice points is either T or
some multiple P times T, where
P is an integer.
And then lickety split, before
you could catch your breath in
wonder, I dropped a
perpendicular down to the
original translation.
This distance in here was PT.
This distance on either
side was T times
the cosine of alpha.
And that led me to a constraint
that alpha, that
rotation operation A alpha, if
it were to be combined with
translation, would be restricted
to values such that
the cosine of alpha was equal
to 1 minus an integer P
divided by 2.
Wow, simple, but so incredibly
profound.
What came out of this
was that alpha could
either be 0 or 360 degrees.
That was a one-fold axis.
Alpha could be 180 degrees.
That was a two-fold axis.
120, which would be the
angular rotation of a
three-fold axis.
90, that would be the operation
of a four-fold axis.
Or 60, that would be the
operation of a six-fold axis.
It's incredible.
Anything, any pattern, any
crystal that is based on a
lattice can contain only these
five rotational symmetries
including no symmetry at all.
So this says a lot about what
the morphology of crystalline
materials are permitted to be.
Then, we looked at the nature
of the lattices that were
described by these angular
rotations.
And we found that there were
only three types of lattices
that were required
by rotation.
These were two dimensional
lattice nets.
One was a general oblique net
which had two different
translations, some arbitrary
angle between them, two
translations, T1 and T2, which
were not equal to one another.
We would call this
the oblique net.
Then, there was another net that
was square in the sense
that two translations,
T1 and T2, were
identical to one another--
not close, but identical.
And the angle between them was
identically 90 degrees.
This oblique net could accept
either a one-fold axis or a
two-fold axis.
This was the specialized shape
that was required by a
four-fold axis.
And then finally, there was
another net that looked
oblique except it was a
specialized oblique net.
It had two translations, T1 and
T2, which were identical
just as in the square net and
an angle between them, which
was exactly 120 degrees.
And this same sort of net
could be compatible with
either a three-fold axis
or a six-fold axis.
Then, we took the only other
operation that could be
present in a two dimensional
pattern, and this was the
operation of reflection,
a mirror point, m.
And we saw that this by itself
could require two different
sorts of specializations in a
lattice, a lattice in which
two directions were exactly
orthogonal but the lengths of
the translations were unequal.
And then, a diamond
shaped net--
and this was a new wrinkle.
This was a net that had two
translations that were
Identical in length and an
arbitrary angle between them.
Or alternatively, if we chose
to pick a redundant lattice,
one that had two translations,
T1 and T2 prime which were
different but an angle between
them that was exactly 90
degrees, so this one we would
refer to as a rectangular
lattice, a rectangular net,
and this one as a centered
rectangular net--
same shape, but an extra lattice
point in the middle.
Why pick a double cell, which
is redundant, takes up more,
and doesn't convey any
more information?
And the advantage comes when
you want to analytically
describe the relation between
different directions or the
positions of atoms
within the cell.
In that case, an orthogonal
coordinate system, even if
it's not Cartesian, is of
immense advantage as opposed
to an oblique system.
OK, slightly out of breath, but
that is everything we've
covered to this point.
And you can find this material
discussed in the first
chapter, in the introduction,
and then half of the second
chapter of Berger's book if
you want to read over it.
OK, any questions or comments?
All right, I wanted to say a
little bit more about lattices
and something with which you
are no doubt familiar, but
perhaps have some questions
about why one does it in such
an obscure, difficult way.
And let me introduce what's done
by an analogy which we
have around us in
everyday life.
Let me draw a system of streets
and avenues for a city
that might be one like Boston
where the streets were laid
out by cows wandering around
in search of forage.
And suppose somebody met you on
the street and said, may I
stop you here at point A
and ask you a question?
How do I get from point
A to point B?
That's not a vector.
That's a point.
How do I do that?
You would not say, go 342 meters
to the east and 26.4
meters to the south.
That's perfectly logical that is
admirably Cartesian but you
wouldn't do it that way what we
just said you would say go
one block straight ahead, and
then turn one block to your
left, and then go down the
street to your right and turn
to your right again, and
you'll be right there.
You can't miss it.
Of course, the person in Boston
would miss it and would
have to stop a second time and
ask again and by a method of
successive approximations
eventually get to where he or
she would like to be.
I submit if a system gives you
a grid, it makes sense to use
that grid as the basis vectors
of coordinate system even if
the intervals are different, in
two different directions,
and even though the intervals
might be not vectors that are
orthogonal to one another.
If the system is periodic and
has this grid work to it, it
makes sense to use that as the
basis of a coordinate system.
So if we have a lattice that
is oblique and there are
lattice points defined by these
two translations, T1 and
T2, it makes great sense if you
want to specify the vector
that runs from this lattice
point to this lattice point to
do that by saying that this is a
lattice point that is at the
end of the vector
1 T1 plus 2 T2.
And that, just as a system of
streets and avenues, is a lot
more efficient than saying go
12.2 angstroms in the x
direction and go 15.3 angstroms
in the y direction.
What we have defined here is
something that is called a
rational direction.
And a rational direction is
something that is going to be
a direction that extends
between lattice points.
And what's rational about it
is that the coefficients in
front of T1 and T2 that would
appear would be integers.
And an integers is sometimes
referred to
as a rational number.
That would be quite different
from a vector that extended
from a lattice point to, let's
say, some atom that is within
the boundaries of this cell.
And this might be a radial
vector from the
origin to one lattice.
And that could be used
to specify the atomic
coordinates.
This is going to complete the
dichotomy, a feature that is
referred to as irrational.
Why?
Because the components of the
steps along T1, x, and along
T2, y, are going to be
fractional numbers.
So you'll hit irrational
notation for directions that
go to different locations
with a unit cell.
You'll use rational vectors in
directions that extend between
integral numbers of
lattice points.
These directions occur all the
time when one discusses the
physical properties
of crystals.
I'm sure in any class that
you've had that's discussed
mechanical properties, one of
the favorite topics is to
discuss the ways in which close
packed metals can deform.
And this can be discussed easily
in terms of one layer
of close packed spheres
sliding over another.
And one of the ways that the
layer can slide to go from one
set of close packed hollows
to another is in a
direction like this.
And that turns out to be
a rational direction.
And these are directions in
which a close packed metal
will easily deform.
So directions of easy plastic
deformations almost always
involve rational directions.
So there is a unique application
of these sorts of
features in the discussion
of mechanical properties.
Another thing that can happen
is that a particular
structure, if it is weakly
bonded or relatively weakly
bonded in one direction, if you
come down with a chisel on
that plane and give it a little
tunk with a hammer, the
crystal will fall exactly in
half and give you two very
smooth surfaces on either
side of some plane.
And the reason is if you look
down into the guts of the
crystal and look at the atoms
and how they're bonded
together, there may be some
direction of weak bonding
between atoms that is very
easily separated by some sort
of mechanical force.
This is true even for crystals
that are very strongly bonded.
The way in which people begin
to facet diamonds, for
example, is to sit for a month
and study the diamond and then
decide how you're going to put a
straight edge to it and give
it a little tunk so that it
falls neatly into two pieces
at the sides that you
want to facet.
Doesn't always work, so you sit
for a long time to figure
out just what you're
going to do.
I think diamond cutters burn
out early and have a useful
career that last perhaps
3 and 1/2 years.
And then, they're burned out.
I don't know that for sure.
But it must be a nerve
wracking way
of making an existence.
Not a far-fetched story.
At one time, I was doing a
diffraction study on a
material which was a low
temperature face, very
interesting, but formed stable
only at such low temperatures
that you could not make it by
cooking the components.
But it had been found as a
mineral in the Swiss Alps, all
sorts of exotica attached to
this particular material.
There was a particular place
up in the Alps which had a
very unusual chemistry involving
lead and arsenic and
thallium and sulfur--
not what you find in your usual
backyard rock pile.
And there was something like 37
unique minerals that were
found in this little spot that
were known nowhere else on the
face of the Earth.
And I was very interested
in the atomic
arrangements in one of them.
So I wrote to the British Museum
that had found the sole
supplier of this
material that--
back in about 1901 or so--
I wrote and I said,
do you have any
crystals of this stuff?
Yes.
Would you like to study it?
And I said yes, I would.
Well, we'd be happy
to send it.
But please be careful not to
damage the morphology because
it is a very rare material.
So I said fine.
I'm as careful as the
next meticulous guy.
They sent two crystals.
The crystals measured--
one of them was 2/10 of a
millimeter in diameter.
One of them was about 0.15
millimeters in diameter.
And I was supposed to take off
a piece for study without
damaging the morphology.
Man, I felt just like one of
these Dutch diamond cutters.
I sat and I looked at those two
little suckers under the
microscope for, I
think, a week.
And then finally, the moment of
truth, and I took a needle
and popped off a corner.
And it went into two pieces.
One went for a microprobe
analysis to determine the
composition.
One of them went to a single
crystal x-ray diffraction
study to determine the
atomic arrangement.
Both analyses can be done on a
very small piece of material.
So my story about the diamond
cutter agonizing before
looking for a cleavage or a
fracture surface is not just
made up fiction.
It is something that, when you
work with crystals very often,
is encountered.
OK, cleavage planes are also
rational directions.
The cleavage plane of rock
salt is legendary.
And it's nice, really, to spend
an afternoon splitting
it up just to see how
neat it falls apart.
OK, how are we going to denote
rational planes?
Talked about rational and
irrational directions, and
that's easy.
How are we going to describe
rational planes in crystals?
And this is rather bizarre.
So let me tell you what you do,
which is something you've
probably heard before, and
then explain why one
does it this way.
Let's suppose we have three
vectors that are the vectors
we will use to define
the lattice.
And if there is a plane hanging
on one of these
lattice points, everything is
translationally periodic, so
there must be a similar plane
in the same orientation that
passes through all the
lattice points.
So let me look at a very special
plane, namely one that
cuts a lattice point at
an integral number of
translations, T3, and an
integral number of
translations, T2, and an
translations, T1.
And I don't want any common
factor here, so let's look at
this point here.
And now, let's connect these
lattice points together.
And that will define
a plane uniquely.
And what is special about this
point is that it hits a
lattice point on each
of these three axes.
And this is a plane that I'll
call the intercept plane.
There will be a similar plane
hanging on all of these other
lattice points.
But those planes will not hit
a lattice point on the
directions of T1, T2, and T3.
This is the first one out from
the origin that does that.
Now, we will use this oblique
set of vectors, T1, T2, and
T3, as the coordinate system
for specifying
direction and angles.
So let me ask a question now
that's going to blow you away.
What is the equation for the
locus of this plane If I use
this oblique coordinate system
based on T1, T2, and T3 as my
coordinate system?
Holy mackerel.
What a way to wrap
up a Tuesday.
Actually, it's very,
very easy.
First of all, it has to
be a linear equation.
So it's going to be linear
in x, y, and z.
So something times x, something
times y, something
times z equals a constant.
That's going to define, if I use
the proper coefficients,
the equation for this plane.
And let me determine quite
easily what those
coefficients are.
What is the coordinate of this
point, which sits on the plane
and therefore must satisfy
this equation?
Well, y is 0. z is zero.
So this is the point--
if I am a translations out from
the origin, this is the
point x equals A.
So if I'm three translations
out from the origin, that
integer is the coefficient in
front of x because when y and
z are 0, if I make the constants
on the right hand
side equal to 1, this is
the point x equals a.
And it's nice to have one
on the right hand side.
That's about as nice and neat
and tidy a constant as you
could have.
We do the same thing for this
point at the end of two
translations, T2.
let's say in general that for
this intercept plane, we are
two translations out along T2.
So for the point 0--
this point, 0--
if I put the number of
translations, b, in front of
y, This is the point y equals
b when x and z are 0.
And in the same way, if we are C
translations out along T3, C
times z-- that integer--
is equal to 1.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
it again?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I'm saying I'm
going to [INAUDIBLE] my
definition at a plane which
cuts the direction of T1,
which is what I called
the variable x, at a
translations out.
In this case, this is 3.
This is 2.
And this is 1.
So for this particular example,
I would have 3x plus
2y plus 1z equals 1 because when
y is 0 and z is 0, the
point on the surface is--
1/3.
Sorry.
Good question.
OK, that's a lot better.
I would've gotten in much deeper
trouble if you had let
me persist in that.
So thank you for
the correction.
But now, I would like to have
integers out in front here.
So let me multiply both sides
through by A times B times C.
And now, I do get something with
integers in front of x
and integers in front of y.
And this would be A times C,
and integers in front of z.
And that's A times B equals--
and now on the right side, I
would have a times B times C.
So everything, every coefficient
and the term on
the right hand side are
products of integers.
So they are all integers
themselves.
OK, let me next ask the question
these planes passing
through all of the other
lattice points that are
contained within this little
tetrahedron of volume are
going to be equally spaced.
How will I claim that these
planes are all equally spaced?
Well, that's easy just
in general terms.
Here is a lattice point.
There's a plane passing
through it.
There's some lattice point
neighboring it that's out at
distance, D. Here is another
lattice point.
It has a plane passing
through it.
There must be a plane out here
on D. And I'm not going to be
able to have the same
environment for every lattice
point unless all of these planes
have the same spacing
from one another.
So to say that they pass in
lattice points in the
environment of everybody lattice
point is by definition
identical is possible only if
the planes are equally spaced.
Next question--
and I'm not going to be gutsy
enough to try to demonstrate
this in three dimensions,
so let me do it in two.
Let us ask the question, how
many planes are there hanging
on all the lattice points
between the origin and the
intercept plane?
And let me demonstrate that for
a two dimensional case.
And I will refer you to a
drawing in Berger's book
because this is not convincing
unless you do
it absolutely exactly.
And to do that in front of a
live audience with chalk is
not always the easiest
thing in the world.
So here is T1.
Here is T2.
And let me look at this plane.
This is the intercept plane.
A is equal to 3 and
B is equal to 2.
Now, what I'm going to do is
to use plus and minus the
translation T1 to repeat
this intercept plane.
OK, I go minus T1.
And that's going to give
me a plane in here.
I'm going to go minus
T1 again.
And that's going to give
me a plane in here.
So I have split the interval
between the origin and the
intercept plane into A parts.
OK so far?
Let me now use the
translation T2.
And I will use the plus and
minus the translation T2 to
take this stack of A planes
and repeat it B times.
And that's going to take the
plane at the origin and move
it up to here.
It's going to move the planes
into stacks like this.
I will map the stack of
A planes B times.
And that is going to give me A
times B intervals except if a
special condition applies.
And then, I will go back
to it in a moment.
This is the equation of
the intercept plane.
I will argue that the three
dimensional analogy of what
I've done is that there will be,
if I let the translations
T1, T2, and T3 go to work, there
will be A times B times
C intervals between the origin
and the intercept plane.
So if this is the intercept
plane and this is A times B
times C times the spacing
between the planes out from
the origin, then the first plane
from the origin is going
to happen to intercept which
is 1ABC to the first.
And ABC divided by ABC turns out
to be 1 for any value of
A, B, and C.
So the first plane from the
origin is going to have the
simple equation be BC times x
plus AC times y plus AB times
z equals 1.
And the second plane out from
the origin will have the same
coefficients except the term
on the left will be 2.
Third plane will have 3 on the
right and finally the integer
ABC when we get to the
intercept plane.
OK, now I'm ready to make a
momentous definition just as
we get five of the hour.
B times C is an integer.
Let me define that integer
by a single integer.
And just for the heck of it,
I'll call it H. A times C is
an integer.
Let me call that integer K.
And AB is an integer.
Let me call that integer L.
So using T1 and T2 and T3 as
the basis vectors of my
coordinate system, the first
plane from the origin has the
equation Hx plus Ky
plus Lz equals 1.
And these three integers, H, K,
and L, are said to be the
Miller indices of this plane.
PROFESSOR: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Just on that figure,
[INAUDIBLE] connect to the
lattice points.
I'm trying to make sense of why
did you put the planes in
between them?
PROFESSOR: OK, what I did was
I started with just these
three hanging on the lattice
point separated by T1.
And then, I move this by T2.
OK, so T2 has a plane
in the middle of it.
And it's going to move
that up to here and
give me another plane.
If you just draw this out--
and you're going to get a
problem that asks
you to do this--
since these integers are
mutually prime, the second
translation is going to
interleave planes
between the first set.
And it gets even worse in three
dimensions because the
third translation, which is the
axis C translations out,
is going to interleave that
set of AB planes C times.
And they have to be at
equal distances.
Otherwise, the definition of
the lattice point having
identical environment
is violated.
OK, these are the infamous
Miller indices that are the
downfall of all freshman
who take 309.1.
It is not necessarily a very
straightforward definition.
But the advantage of it is that
it lets you analytically
describe the locus of the
lattice planes in a very, very
convenient way.
Actually, let me tell you
something maybe you have not
heard before.
These indices were not invented
by a fellow named
Miller who was an Englishman
who wrote a book, an early
book on crystallography that
incorporated this notation.
The guy who invented them and
first proposed them was
Auguste Bravais, a very famous
French crystallographer--
mathematician, actually--
who gave his name to the three
dimensional space lattices.
These are universally
known as the Bravais
lattices, 14 of them.
It's a great name.
It's music. it rolls
of the tongue--
Bravis, Bravais.
Actually, Bravias wasn't
the first guy to
try to derive them.
The first guy who tried to
drive the lattices was
somebody named Frankenheim.
He blew it.
He didn't get 14.
He only found 13.
So there's a moral here.
If immortality is your game,
get it right the first time
because everybody has heard
of Bravais, Bravais.
Nobody has heard
of Frankenheim.
And for that, I say thank god.
What a name!
It makes you think of somebody
who's got plugs in his neck
and walks around like this
and has a green face.
Frankenheim--
bah!
Bravais, Bravais, it really
sings to you.
OK, I'm getting silly so it's
time to quit and take a break.
Come up and say hello
to Rodney.